non
[Musique]
il est à peine midi
katia prépare les quatrièmes obsèques de
la journée c'est une macabre routine qui
s'est installée ici même pour ce petit
salon funéraire un tel rythme est
complètement anormal
il y en a tous les jours quatre
aujourd'hui 4 demain fait une erreur en
venir c'est notre troisième guerre
mondiale dit-elle concentrer les yeux
rivés sur les petites lettres dorées qui
rendent hommage au défunt dans la pièce
en arrière une équipe préparent le
cercueil
il est pour un homme qui a succombé à la
coved à l'hôpital confirme alex un
employé blâmant le vécu il dit que la
famille ne pourra même pas voir le corps
ceux qui meurent infectés sont enterrés
enveloppés dans un sac de plastique mans
devant l'hôpital qui nous dit on est
plein à craquer un camion vient de
s'arrêter pour le ravitaillement
d'oxygène alors qu'un autre kit avec un
cadeau nous sommes à aniane doma une
ville de 25000 habitants du nord de la
russe nous avons parcouru 1000 km depuis
moscou pour comprendre l'impact de la
pandémie n'a cédé éloignés elles sont
les grandes oubliées du système de santé
des infrastructures rongé par le temps
du personnel de santé dévoué et qui
manque cruellement de moyens
anastase est infirmière son mari pavel
et chef du syndicat des ambulanciers
ils nous ont donné rendez vous dans un
garage où au moins quatre ambulances
sont paralysés il n'y a pas d'argent ou
simplement pas de volonté ce contrat
avec ce sont eux les chauffeurs qui
essaye de les réparer entre deux quarts
de travail qu'il a pris l'initiative de
faire parce qu'ils travaillent ce soir
hier c'était la folie dit-il
je ne sais plus à quoi matin nous avons
retrouvé le soir même aux urgences
complètement débordés la deuxième vague
et virulente et on fait ce qu'on peut
dit le docteur bladimir bout de ses
rayons
emilie secours pour toute la région ils
n'osent pas se plaindre
de toute façon il n'a pas le temps
s'arrête ça peut à peine cinq minutes
qu'on est arrivé dans la caserne
ambulance et déjà 4e ville qui a été
signalée on se prépare à aller chercher
il ya seulement deux ambulances qui
fonctionne cette semaine pour toute la
ville
si la réalité ici d'une médecin on en
sait plus quoi illustrer chili à moscou
puis il reste de la russie
si dans la capitale les autorités
étaient fiers de nous ouvrir les portes
de cet hôpital dernier cri mis sur pied
pour l'aco vide ici dans nord la
direction aura tout fait pour nous
empêcher de parler à des patients ou à
des employés le mari de la directrice en
est même pris physiquement à pavel qui a
dû se défendre en attendant la police
une tension vive une omerta qui en dit
long sur la réalité qu'on préfère ne pas
montrer des édredons soulier de la
moisissure des plafonds et des murs
fissurés comme en témoignent ces images
tournées par un syndicat ne plus cacher
près d'un arrêt d'autobus pour
rencontrer des femmes de ménage va plus
les femmes en colère surchargées à qui
on demande aussi de changer des couches
et de veiller sur les patients sans
protection nécessaire comme des gants et
des masques de qualité a beau mouton
survenue risque notamment été le bruit
ni hector elle gagne en moyenne dix neuf
mille roubles par mois l'équivalent de
325 $
dénoncer ses conditions de travail dans
les villes les plus pauvres de russie
est devenue une des missions principales
d'anastasia qui a accepté plus tard de
nous recevoir à la maison
c'est la pandémie aura révélé l'ampleur
du déclin de la médecine en région et
s'il ya de l'argent dit elle
nous ne voyons pas ici n'ont ni le plus
tôt mais les clauses tonnes elle est
mère de famille infirmières et travaille
pour l'alliance médicale ce syndicat
national indépendant
le seul qui ose tenir tête au
gouvernement vladimir poutine ça veut
dire qu'elle est constamment dans la
mire de la police souvent harcelés comme
ce fut le cas quand sa chef anastasia
vassilieva est venu en ville au début du
mois pour distribuer l'équipement et
contrôler les mesures d'hygiène
[Musique]
même au salon funéraire personne n'a été
capable de vous dire combien de
personnes meurent de la cobi encore
moins combien en sont atteints de toute
façon ils manipulent les statistiques du
propriétaire pour lui de changer notre
style est ici selon lui le résultat d'un
régime qui depuis vingt ans se fout
complètement des gens ordinaires
des régions laissées à elles-mêmes
pleine pandémie une tragédie dont on ne
connaîtra probablement jamais la
véritable enfant